okay hello everyone uh welcome back
after a few week hiatus to uh
science and technology q a for kids and
others
i was off for a few weeks here because
we are doing our annual
uh
summer school and high school summer
camp
lots of interesting projects lots of
interesting students
and
lots of fun for me lots of opportunity
to learn about new things not only for
the students but also for me
um anyway we're back now and i'm happy
to
try and take questions about uh
any kind of aspect of science and
technology see whether i can answer them
i'd like to remind people that there's a
big archive now that's been building up
of uh
the last well basically two years of um
uh q and a's
they should be pretty nicely indexed and
pretty easy to find different kinds of
questions and
i'm trying to kind of avoid answering
the same question too many times here
and
although i certainly don't remember
where everything is uh sort of referring
people to the things i've talked about
before
so let's see we have a bunch of
questions that got saved up here
um
the uh
we have a new one just um
um
all right let's see maybe i'll i'll jump
into this new one from vass
asking what does the concept of the
ruling ad say about teleportation
okay that's not so simple but uh let's
let's see where we can go with this
so
what does teleportation mean
so usually when things move
if i move if i walk if i move from here
to somewhere else
i
am
one place now
and then i go through all the
intermediate places to get to the place
i'm going to in other words what doesn't
it doesn't happen that
i'm in my first place and then i just
disappear
and then i re-materialize in the place
i'm going to
and you know the star trek science
fiction television series from the 1960s
there was this concept of a transporter
where somebody would step onto this kind
of pad and they would kind of uh be
disintegrated and then they would
reappear on a pad somewhere else or
actually not always a pad just they
would reappear somewhere else having
been reconstituted
that's for material objects like people
for example
that's not how things currently can be
made to work if you want to go from here
to there you've got to be at every
intermediate place in going from one
place to the other
now it's a little trickier because
imagine that
you wanted to take something like a
a plastic
dinosaur figurine
and you wanted to transport that to
somewhere else well one thing you could
do
is put it in a 3d scanner have it
have a digital representation of that
dinosaur figurine created
take that digital representation
send it
as
in some electronic or
or optical form
to another place
where you've got a 3d printer
and then you print the dinosaur again
and it's as if
you had you teleported the dinosaur from
where it was to where it's going
without it never existing in the
intermediate places because it only
existed in digital form as sort of a 3d
geometry description of how the dinosaur
should be reconstituted
so in a sense one kind of practical
version of sort of teleportation
is you take the object you kind of
analyze what it's like
maybe you analyze it destructively maybe
you destroy it maybe you just take it
apart atom by atom you might use let's
say a i don't know an
atomic force microscope or something to
like pick off atom by atom the original
object then you have a representation of
where all the atoms are you send that in
digital form to another place and then
you reassemble it and then and they
place it it ended up now nobody knows
how to do that right now
there are an awful lot of atoms in
a person let's say there are on the
order of well
uh a one with maybe 27 zeros after it so
a trillion trillion
billion billion trillion trillion atoms
or something in a person
and turning that into kind of digital
information sending it and so on far
beyond what current technology can do
but that's sort of one concept of how
you might sort of go from one place to
another without being in the
intermediate places
now that's
the there's another form of
teleportation which
uh people talk about which comes from
quantum mechanics
so this this gets pretty tricky and is
very deeply informed by things that we
figured out very very recently uh well
in some cases just in the last couple of
years in other cases in the matter of
the last few months or weeks
about kind of how quantum mechanics
works so let's see if i can describe a
little bit the idea of this
so first point to realize is
that
in sort of standard classical physics
in the kind of physics that got sort of
initiated in the 1600s with newton and
people like that
there are equations of motion that
describe how things move so for example
you throw something it moves in this
parabolic trajectory and there's an
equation that says at every moment
there's a certain acceleration a certain
force on the object due to gravity that
will and there's a certain initial
velocity and you have an equation that
says exactly how the thing will move and
it's a a definite equation that
describes a definite trajectory that the
thing should follow
that's how sort of classical physics
works
big idea of about 100 years ago now
is uh what's what's called modern
physics although eventually that term
modern of modern physics will have to be
retired um i i like to think that um
what we've done in the last couple of
years with our physics project is kind
of the next big stage of the description
of physics and i think it needs a name
maybe somebody can suggest a name you
know there are all these textbooks of
modern physics but there will eventually
be textbooks of the physics we invented
in the last few years and i don't know
what they'll be called um i don't think
they should be called post-modern
physics
but
that's that's kind of a challenge of
naming that in any case in so-called
modern physics which is actually 100
years old um the uh
the key idea is this idea of quantum
mechanics
and
the notion
so it's a little bit confusing in terms
of naming because the reason it got
called quantum mechanics
is because
things that people thought were
continuous
ended up being broken into quantized
discrete pieces
so for example big idea from max planck
and albert einstein from around 1900 to
1905-ish time frame was the idea that
light is not just a continuous
uh sort of flow of electromagnetic
energy it is broken into discrete quanta
which which we call photons that's the
quantization of um
uh
of the electromagnetic field
well uh the the general belief was lots
of things are quantized or discrete and
that's sort of one of the features of
quantum mechanics but it's in the end
it's probably not the most important
feature of quantum mechanics
um
the uh one of the confusing things is at
that time people thought space and time
might also be quantized but they
couldn't figure out how to make that
work in terms of the sort of formalism
and mathematics of thinking about that
we finally figured that out as part of
our physics project in the last couple
of years of the idea of how space and
time can really be discrete um and yet
we get all of the things that we're used
to observing about features of space and
time and so on
okay but back to quantum mechanics so i
think the big idea as we think about
quantum mechanics today
is that instead of definite things
happening you know you throw something
that follows a definite trajectory
instead there's a whole giant kind of
branching merging collection of possible
trajectories
and
each of those possible trajectories
represents something that sort of could
happen
and actually what the idea that is in
its most extreme form happens in the
ruling ad
but in what we call multi-way systems
the idea is that in the universe
everything actually does happen many
things actually happen
our experience says that there's a
definite thread of time that we imagine
we when we think about
our sort of life and times we normally
imagine that oh this happened then this
happened then this happened
not at any given time all these
different things were happening all in
parallel um and uh you know we think
definite things happen in the sort of
classical physics kind of way
but in our modern view of these things
we think about multi-way systems where
there are many parts of history that are
being uh traced out
so then the big surprise is if in fact
the universe is following many parts of
history why do we think that definite
things happen
well this is where things get a bit
trickier because we ourselves are
embedded in this multi-way system that
is the universe so just as every aspect
of the universe is branching and all
these different possible parts of
history are happening that's also
happening in our brains
so in a sense the question of how we
perceive the universe is a question of
how a branching brain
perceives a branching universe
so that's a it's a kind of a complicated
concept because our brains are
sort of branching and doing all these
different things but we imagine that
definite things happen so effectively
what we're doing is we're conflating
when we're we're converging these
different threads of history that our
brains are following
we
in our sort of thinking about what's
going on are sort of taking all those
different parts of history and
considering them to be one part of
history
the non-trivial fact is that that
doesn't lead to weird inconsistencies in
what we think happens in the world that
eventually it will be even though okay
this is where again it gets tricky
even though there are effects that we
say that's a quantum effect
where where it does matter that there
are multiple parts of history at any
given time
on a large scale in terms of our sort of
everyday experience it is consistent to
just assume that all these parts of
history are really saying the same thing
now again it gets even trickier here
because
different
human minds
different people in different places
different whatever
they can have a different perception of
what happens in the universe their
internal perception of what happens in
the universe we know it more or less
agrees person to person you say you know
we're sitting in the same room what's
happening here people will give more or
less the same description of what's
happening but internal to their brains
the actual pattern of neural firings
that is the their internal description
of what's happening in that room will be
different between those different people
there's just a sort of a common
understanding a kind of course-grained
level of understanding that seems the
same
but so sort of a critical idea is this
idea that
even though the universe is branching in
all these different ways we sort of
imagine a definite thing is happening
because we conflate all those branches
together when we imagine how we
experience things
sort of the analogy to that in a
slightly different domain
is if we think about oh we've just got
uh you know air in this room well we
don't really have air in this room we
have a gazillion different individual
molecules that are bouncing around we
just describe that in this sort of large
scale
way as just a bunch of gas that is that
we call air
um but the idea that we can just
experience all those molecules bouncing
around as that overall gas
that's a consequence of the fact that
we're pretty big compared to the
individual gas molecules and we're kind
of aggregating the effects of all those
individual gas molecules to say it just
performs like this this sort of
large-scale continuum gas
now in the case of quantum mechanics
what's going on is that we are
aggregating all these little threads of
history that are like all the little
molecules bouncing around but there are
actual threads of history rather than
just molecules or something but we're
aggregating all those thirds of history
and and we're concluding that there's
sort of a bulk thing that happens in
more or less the same way that we
conclude that there's a bulk thing that
happens in the air even though the air
is made of all those discrete molecules
okay so what does this have to do with
teleportation
all right so
when you look at these different threads
of history
at any given time
in sort of you can say let me let me
find a description of the universe at
this moment in time
the description of the universe will
have many threads of history in it there
will be many distinct threads if you
want to find how precisely the precise
state of the universe there are many
possible precise states of the universe
on all of these different threads
okay point number one point number two
it's also the case
that
when we say what's the state of the
universe
we are
describing
um
there's also different places in space
in the universe
and when we say
what's the current state of the universe
it's tricky to know
what
okay so let me describe it this way so
let's say the star nearest two hours uh
other than the nearest to the sun alpha
centauri let's say there's some
uh tremendous thing that happens alpha
centauri blows up it's not really going
to happen for
a very long time if ever i think um but
let's say something something happens
maybe there was a maybe there's let's
say there's an alien civilization that
lives on a planet near alpha centauri
and they suddenly uh decide to
launch a big ad campaign and they've got
this giant unfurling huge ad that says
you know
uh
you know buy alpha centauri cookies or
something
and they do that at some moment
okay
that star is four light years away from
us
so
the moment where they unfurl their giant
cookie ad
we won't see the reflect of that for
four years because that's how long it
takes light to go from that star to us
but if they said well when did you
unfurl the giant cookie ad
was it at 12 noon on january 1st of this
year
well
what do we say did we receive it on 12
noon january 1st of that year
did they have their own calendar running
and they said oh it was january 1st but
of course that's not the same january
1st that we there's no conversion from
their january 1st to our january 1st
because there's a four year delay in
sending the light signal from one to
another so it becomes sort of an
arbitrary thing whether you synchronize
their calendar
to be how you synchronize their calendar
with our calendar
so this leads to the idea of reference
frames and the idea of foliations of
space-time and this whole notion of how
simultaneity works
and the arbitrariness with which you can
choose kind of where their calendar is
relative to our calendar
so that's sort of another
uh it's all a bit complicated actually
the so so there's this kind of way of
choosing different notions of
simultaneity in physical space
the same is true across these different
threads of history in what we call
branchial space the space of different
quantum branches all those different
threads are different quantum branches
and you can imagine all those threads
being kind of laid out
in something that is like physical space
but it isn't physical space
two threads can be considered to be
nearby if they have a common ancestor
soon before them so in other words if
two different threads came from a
branching of one event one one state
earlier on
one state just just very recently then
those two threads are considered to be
still nearby and so from that you can
build up this notion of bombshell space
and you end up with a this idea of
different foliations of bronchial space
different ways to define
simultaneity
not now across different places in space
but across different threads of history
in the universe across different places
in branchial space
okay
how does all of this relate to type
rotation i say again
so the issue is
to say that something is moving
in
gosh how to talk about this
so
okay
so what happens is
in these different branches of history
one can say that the histories of the
universe are entangled because those
different branches of history are
related to each other
they were those two branches they might
have shared a common ancestor so there
was a state of the universe and then it
branched into two possible states of the
universe and so on that leads to those
states of the universe being what we
could say are entangled they're
correlated with each other because they
both came from the same initial state
so one thing that one can then think
about is
given
that different states of the universe
are entangled from common ancestry
how
do you
what you you can have states of the
universe
that are
hell again i'm i have to i have to break
this down a little bit further and it's
going to get a bit complicated here
because we have to start talking about
not only states of the whole universe
but also states of different parts of
space in the universe but let me say
very roughly
that
what you can see happening is
at different places for in different
threads of history
some object might be at different places
in physical space
and
the fact that these two threads of
history are both kind of
have a a common ancestor a recent common
ancestor it's like those two threads of
history are related to each other
they're entangled because they had
common ancestry
yet this object is in a different place
in one of these uh
states than it is in another of these
states
so now what's tricky is to say so so
but but now if if we are perceiving
what's going on we have this weird
situation
where it looks to us if we were to
conflate those two states of the
universe it would seem like this object
is in two different places
we would be confused where is this
object it you know we are conflating
together states of the universe where in
one version the object is in one place
and another version the object is in the
other place and we're imagining
in our minds that those two states of
the universe can be considered the same
for purposes of our sort of single
thread of experience and so that will
tend to confuse us because it looks like
the object is in two places at once
okay but i mentioned that
you can sort of slice bronchial space
differently you can make a difference
sort of
you can say what is simultaneity in
shield space differently just like you
can do that in physical space
how do you in in physical space it's
just this sort of arbitrary choice of oh
i'm going to set the clock to be uh you
know in alpha centauri to be this way
and i'm going to set the clock here to
be this way and so on
but
it's
well let's see
um for example in physical space
if you're moving through physical space
there is sort of a natural way to set
these clocks
that
uh corresponds to a certain state of
motion that you have and if you change
your state of motion the sort of the the
way you set these clocks the sort of
natural way to set these clocks will
differ so you can effectively choose a
different natural way to describe
simultaneity in the universe
by going at a different speed relative
to
a different speed in the universe
well something similar happens in bronze
brownshield space we don't understand it
as well but there's something like
going at a different speed in branchial
space basically having a different
choice of simultaneity in bronchial
space
and
those different choices so when you have
different choices of simultaneity that
object that i said in one branch of
history was in one place another branch
of history was in another place in those
different uh ways of of foliating
branchial space effectively those
different sort of perceptions of how you
put together those different branches of
history you will have a different
conclusion about where the object is
and so
that can lead to an effect that seems
like teleportation because you can if
you change your point of view about
what's going on which seems like an
internal thing for you to do
it'll be as if the object moves from
this place to that place and it's sort
of all on you in the way that you're
doing what people would say in sort of
more traditional physics is kind of the
way you're doing the quantum
measurements and so on will cause the
object to be in one place versus another
place
but it's not really something which you
can harvest
because to do that
you kind of have to
you're sort of changing the way your
brain is set up and if you change the
way your brain is set up it's like you
know you're almost putting you know the
object is moving because first you had
your hand over one eye and then over the
other eye yes the object seems to move
it's kind of something more like that
than it is the idea that the thing sort
of materially moves from one place to
another
so
the um
so that's kind of the the sort of
there's this branchial form of of um of
motion there's this form of motion that
just comes from taking a different point
of view about branchial space
um which is sort of not real motion
probably of course it depends because it
is real motion if for other reasons so
to speak you're sort of changing your
your way of sampling bronchial space
then it might seem like real motion to
you
but
it's not something where you can say
it's something where the motion is sort
of in the eye of the beholder now again
it's quite complicated because you could
say the same thing about motion and
physical space relative to the way that
you foliate physical space
um
and and you'd be right to say that
because if you know the thing isn't
moving
you say is it moving in space well i'm
right next to it and i'm moving with it
well then it doesn't seem to be moving
and so you have the same issue there but
we're more familiar with the notion that
it's moving and then we're stationary
we're not moving et cetera we don't yet
understand very well this idea of kind
of motion in branchial space so it's a
little bit more mysterious what's what's
going on there
now
i could say another thing as well
which is about the kind of the earlier
form of teleportation that i described
where you you take a thing you kind of
deconstruct it
into pure digital information then you
reconstruct it somewhere else
okay well in our model of physics
everything is pure digital information
the whole structure of the universe is
just made up of a of a giant collection
of atoms of existence atoms of space
that have certain relations to each
other that's all there is in the
universe and all of our experiences in
the universe are just us
having a certain perception of what's
going on there
uh us built from the same stuff by the
way
so
here's the thing when you imagine a
physical object
moving from here to there well first of
all what is a physical object the whole
universe is just made of these atoms of
space connected in certain ways it's
this giant network of atoms of space
so a physical object is something which
has some degree of persistence through
time
in that or or at least some some aspect
of it has some degree of persistence
through time the analogy that's
convenient is to think about a fluid
like water and to think about vortices
and water little swirls in the water or
an air you know a tornado or something a
tornado is made of just molecules of air
but there's a certain overall structure
overall uh way that the air is moving
and that has a certain persistence to it
even though it's made of different
molecules of air at every successive
moment in time so similarly the idea in
our model of physics is that everything
works that way so for example a particle
like an electron is just some little
region of of connections in the
structure of space
that has the feature that it remains
that the structure of that collection of
connections remains coherent consistent
through time and that's why the electron
sort of can can move and not change its
character even though the electron at
every successive moment in time is made
of different atoms of space
like the vortex and the fluid it
maintains some kind of uh
some kind of engram of itself some kind
of trace of itself
that is independent of the specific
atoms of space at which it's made
so when you say i'll move a material
object through space
what's happening is you're taking the
electrons and the quarks and all those
kinds of things and those sort of little
vortex like things that represent those
those things are moving through this
kind of fabric that is this hypograph as
well this this this network of
connections between atoms of space
so
that that's what how ordinary motion
works ordinary motion is a persistent
thing
a bit like a vortex
gets to move through the structure of
space
okay
but now
and and by the way the the speed at
which it can move through the structure
of space is on average at most the speed
of light
and that's not too hard to eventually to
see why that is
um it's basically because every little
uh effect of one atom of space on the
neighboring atom of space to which it's
connected
the the um uh the
the the time there's a certain
elementary time that it takes
every every every update of the
structure of the network takes a certain
time
and what one will say happens is that
this network we can think of the
different connections in the network as
also being a certain elementary distance
apart and the ratio of the elementary
distance to the elementary time is the
speed of light
and
so in a sense effects in this in this
very low level network
effects
necessarily sort of move at the speed of
light
but what's complicated is the structure
of space
they move microscopically at the speed
of light but what that means for for
what they what happens on a larger scale
for example that whole electron it could
be that some little tentacle of the
electron
moves uh
it it goes sort of at the speed of light
relative to this network but the whole
structure of space
might
the space is being made up from the same
network
and so the question of whether
the the sort of every part of the
electron moves at speed of light
has to do with how you assess where it's
moving and that depends on the structure
of space
so for example there's a little little
special place where there's a little
thread in the structure of space
where one atom of space is directly
connected to an atom of space that
otherwise in most ways of getting to the
other atom's space involves some long
path but there happens to be this little
thread of connection between them that's
kind of like a space tunnel it's kind of
like a place where two parts of the
universe are connected sort of in in
less distance
than corresponds to the normal uh way
you would travel from one to the other
so okay so then
okay so let's go back to the
teleportation idea
so we've got this electron it's this big
fluffy thing that's like a vortex that's
made of lots of atoms of space
but
the question is
can you
let's say you have a tiny space tunnel
can you squeeze that electron through
the tiny space tile well no you you
can't
as such it's a big fluffy thing that's
made of lots of atoms of space
and the space tunnel is like only let's
say three atoms of space wide or
something like this how do you get it
through well you can't as such as an
electron but if you could deconstruct
that electron into just some pattern of
atoms of space that would sort of fit
through that space channel then you
might be able to get the atom of space
that you get the electron to the other
side of the space tunnel and to
somewhere different in space
in a sense more quickly an ordinary
motion of that electron would correspond
so the question of can you take apart
the electron and turn it into sort of
features of the atoms of each features
of space that can be propagated faster
through a space tunnel that's technology
far in our future um and because you
know we are
we are trillion trillion trillion times
bigger at least
no more trillions
about probably
trillion trillion still in 10 times or
something bigger
than the atoms of space we are and sort
of the the most microscopic things we
can manipulate
are maybe a million trillion times
smaller than that we are
which is far far
bigger than anything that's down at the
level of atoms of space so we don't have
any idea yet how to manipulate things
down at the size scale of the atoms of
space
whether
uh
you know never say never because
it's uh you know if you look at the
history of technology one is continually
figuring out sort of engineering
solutions that let one leverage pieces
of the physical universe in ways that we
hadn't expected before i mean right now
it's seeming like the only ways you get
down to things on the scales of atoms of
space
might be in very extreme situations with
black holes and things like this
but i'm not counting it out but there's
a way to do it uh using things that are
more sort of uh everyday
everyday capabilities we just don't know
how to do that yet
so so anyway so that's that's the
that's uh the rough idea here now
now when it comes i mean this is even
more extreme when it comes to the
rouliad so quantum mechanics
is a story of
there are many different things that
could happen but in a sense they're all
the um
the same
uh it's sort of the same underlying rule
that's being applied but being applied
in different ways to make these
different branches of history in the
ruliad one talks about not just a
particular rule being applied but all
possible rules all possible
computational programs can be applied
and the ruliad is the entangled limit of
all those possible ways of
all those possible applications of all
those possible programs
so
the just like i was saying
you know we as human observers of
branchial space
we kind of conflate together regions of
bronchial space and say definite things
happened so do we do the same thing in
rule space
we are conflating
different
small regions of rule space where we say
we're assuming the set we can imagine
that the same thing happens here
we don't understand all of these things
in as much detail as as one eventually
will
but um sort of the the um
this question of what does teleportation
look like in rural space
uh wow i haven't really thought about
that terribly much
um
uh i think
this idea
yeah i mean it's kind of wild actually
this um
this idea of kind of quantum
teleportation
where
you are sort of changing your point of
view about the universe to imagine that
things are in different places the same
will happen in real space
so in other words uh one can imagine
different minds effectively
that operate according to different
rules that exist in different places in
rural space
might actually conclude that things were
will
can conclude that things are in
different places in for example physical
space
and so
if you were to transition from one mind
to another you might conclude that
something was in a different place so if
you
and to make a silly way to say it change
your mind but by change your mind i
really mean
you know you are changing the structure
of your mind
not just
you change what you're thinking in your
mind but you change the very structure
by which your mind operates
then i could imagine
that that you can get essentially rulial
teleportation
um in which something effectively moves
from one place to another because you've
changed your view of the universe which
causes you to believe that it's a
different place because you're going on
a different branch of in in rural space
a different branch of the rouhiad
effectively
so that was a little complicated i i
apologize for the complexity there but
that's some a little bit of a story
about teleportation i would say that the
um
the concept of kind of breaking things
down
into their
underlying
sort of elements
to transport them around the sort of
first form of teleportation i described
is um is something you can also imagine
doing in rural space
where you kind of break down anything
into the atoms of existence that it
contains
then you essentially reconstitute those
atoms with exist atoms of existence
somewhere else
um
i do imagine
that
sort of our view of how you
how you move the analog of a particle
like an electron that maintains its
coherence as it travels from one place
in physical space to another the analog
of that in real space is probably rather
complicatedly is probably the idea of
concepts so if you have two minds that
operate in different ways according to
different rules they're effectively in
different places in rural space the
question is how do you move something
from one mind to another
you know you can't take a sort of
transplant of these are the neural net
neural firings in one mind and just say
let's take the detailed electrical
signals in the in the hundred billion
neurons that are in one mind and apply
them to the hundred billion neurons that
are in another mind that's not going to
work instead you have to have a
transport layer that allows you to take
some aggregated version
of the thoughts of the first mind and
transport them to the second mind
and basic way we do that is through
language and through the idea of
concepts
a concept is some kind of thing that you
know the concept of a keyboard or
something
is a
a concept that is sort of the aggregate
of lots of individual neuron firings in
one mind and it causes
to ingest that concept in another mind
causes a lot of other detailed neural
firings in that mind but that's a sort
of the robust transport layer that goes
between one mind and another
more elaborately this whole idea of
computational language the thing i've
spent the last many decades working on
this whole way of sort of of of
translating from what is a mind level
thing a human mind level thing to what
is a pure computational thing that's the
role of wolfram language is to let you
write you know i don't know
uh you know table
you know
uh
x squared x goes from one to ten or
something that that is a human level
representation a human understandable
representation of a piece of computation
which ultimately will be implemented
ultimately be implemented down in the
rouliad at the level of atoms of space
uh in the intermediate it is represented
by electrons in your computer's cpu and
all those kinds of things
but the question of sort of how you take
that
that the how you take the computation
that we imagine in our minds and
translate it the role of wolfen language
is to represent
the those aspects of of possible
computations that are ones that humans
care about like tables of x squared and
things like this
as opposed to just the unbelievably
incoherent kind of characteristics of
lots of gazillions of atoms of space or
gazillions of atoms of existence just
sort of being updated in some
complicated way it's it's like saying
when we see a vortex and a fluid for
example we say oh look there's a little
eddy in our water
whereas if we see some complicated piece
of turbulence or we were to look down
through a very powerful microscope and
see all the or see all the molecules
bouncing around we wouldn't have
anything particularly to say about them
other than well there are a lot of
molecules bouncing around we wouldn't
have sort of a collective statement to
make
what
language concepts
ultimately computational language what
those represent are the kind of
aggregated concepts that we fished out
of the underlying sort of detail of
what's happening at the level of atoms
of existence what's happening at the
level of sort of the lowest level of the
ruliad
so this question of of what it means
to to move in rulial space
and what moves in rule space it's really
taking things like concepts things that
can be represented in language and those
are things which we can expect to be
robust as we move them across real space
so what would it mean to teleport in
rural space it would mean that you take
the concepts in your mind in a mind
and you start somehow moving them not at
the level of big concepts that are
heavily aggregated but somehow you move
them down at the level of individual
like maybe neuron firings but much much
lower level than that but we could just
think about it in terms of neuron
firings
you are you are just taking that series
of neuron firings and trying to move it
to another brain so let's give an
analogy i think they can see how this
might work
so let's say you've got a brain and
you've got some
uh you know neural connection so you're
measuring the electrical impulses in a
few nerve cells in your brain and there
you have these spike trains you know
they make you know
you know kinds of things as your nerves
are firing you've got all of those
things happening in some region of your
brain
and then you say let's take that
that's at the level that's at a very
granular level a very low level let's
take that baby thing
and let's move it to another brain
well good luck you know that
beep thing might represent
the i'm i want a piece of chocolate
but
it's much lower level than the sort of
concept level of i want a piece of
chocolate
the i want a piece of chocolate level
is transportable to another brain but
the bbb beep level at the level of
individual neurons is not normally
transportable to another brain
but you could imagine some funky system
where you encode something that you know
it starts as a concept in your brain
then you record certain detailed beep
beep things from individual neurons you
move those to another brain you kind of
reconstitute the concept the concept not
by sort of having it go all the way
through your vocal cords saying
something your auditory system hearing
something not through that transport
layer but instead through some kind of
direct neuron to neuron transport layer
where it's reconstituted at the other
end of course we don't know how to do
that right now
um but it's kind of the idea that you
know you could imagine
um uh you can imagine something where
you kind of take the nerve nerve firings
from one person you kind of you extract
them from one person you re-implant them
in another person and they give the same
idea to that other person now normally
that doesn't happen that way but one
could that would be sort of the
teleportation of ideas would be uh sort
of having something like that happen i'm
reminded a chap i i knew once had this
had this thing where he wanted to have
sort of direct neural communication with
that particular case i think his wife
where he had this implanted uh
thing that measured the um in his arm
that measured uh kind of not quite i
think
measure the uh
the sort of nerve impulses which were
making muscles contract
and so and then you know his his wife or
something
some other person i'm not sure who had a
had sort of a copy of this so in a sense
it's like one person moves their finger
and then that is transmitted by
you know by some radio or bluetooth or
something like this
to the other person that fact is picked
up in a sensor in one person's arm and
is moved to through bluetooth to um
another person's arm and then it is used
as a nerve impulse than the other
person's arm and um the uh
um and then so that you know one person
moves their finger and the other person
sort of under remote control is is at
least urged to move their finger there's
there's some impulse in their in their
nerves in their in their arm that causes
that muscle to be to be moved so it's
kind of like that's that's almost like
the teleportation of ideas a very low
level version of the teleportation um
uh of of of ideas
let's see that was a long description
here so let's see i think there's
there's some
lots of
questions here
um
let's see if there are ones that um
uh
okay about this physics topic let me
just look at a few of these
uh
l
ll
asks so he experiences a single state of
the universe already something different
branches to build our experience
i we are sampling different branches to
build our experience but actually
the way we think about it right now
we are
sort of making assumptions about this is
the same as that
to make those branches uh sort of
conflate with each other
i'm not sure that's necessarily the
right way to think about it i think the
way you describe it of something
different branches to build our
experience is probably a more accurate
way to describe it um from a sort of
mathematical point of view the simplest
thing we can do is just say we're
building up a set of equations that say
this branch is the same as that branch
but i don't think that's necessarily the
right way to think about it i think it
may be better to say we're really
aggregating these branches to build our
experience
so yes that's that's right
um
okay so there's a question here
uh from um
aaron if the speed of light emerges from
propagation through discrete eams then
does the speed of light very slightly
could this be experimentally validated
okay so
even in traditional physics
uh
well let's see depends what you mean by
the speed of light
uh you know
in a black hole
a photon is pulled so much back by
gravity that it doesn't move out from a
black hole so in a sense you could
describe that as saying the speed of
light is zero at a black hole because
light is pulled back to be stationary
but in fact the usual way one describes
things in terms of the causal
relationships between one event another
you still imagine you say the speed of
light is what the speed of light always
is it's just that space has been
distorted
to the point where even though lights
running at the all you know is going as
as as fast as it normally would space
has been so distorted that even going at
that speed it doesn't get anywhere
so
in a sense there's sort of a trade-off
between the distortion of space
describing things in terms of the
distortion of space and describing
things in terms of a change in speed of
light
but it gets even more complicated in our
models of space time because you can
change the dimension of space as well as
changing
the uh
the curvature the the kind of um the the
distances within space
so
i think it's the case that um
uh you can parametrize
you can describe at least in a first
approximation changes in dimension that
might happen in the early universe and
places like that as a variation in the
speed of light
and
what you will see
experimentally you could describe
the presence of
you know even in traditional physics you
could describe the presence of gravity
as leading to a change of the speed of
light it's not the way it's usually
described but you could talk about
things that way
um and so similarly it's like when when
light bends as it goes around the sun
but as a result of the effect of gravity
you can think about that as being a like
what happens when light goes into water
it changes its speed as it goes into
water and you know it it bends the the
um you know the stick looks bent in the
water it's it's the same sort of thing
it's just usually talked about in a
different way in terms of space time
but um uh yes so i think that the
the um
uh in a sense whenever there's gravity
you can think about it as being sort of
like a change in speed of light but now
we have this additional thing of
dimension change which is even more like
that and so yes there are probably
experimental consequences of this
and whether
the fact that space-time is not is not
uniform that there's it's sort of lumpy
and uh things can propagate you know
things are not just sort of smoothly
moving through space they're moving
through space sort of one atom of space
at a time but usually those atoms of
space are so tiny that doesn't matter
it's just like you know on your screen
you can see a little pac-man that's
moving around on your screen maybe
actually that's a bad example because
it's usually done in very low resolution
graphics but if you zoom out you can see
this picture of a you know
your sort of uh virtual squid moving
around on the screen and it might look
like it's continuously moving around
even though you know that really it's
moving from one pixel to another to
another but it looks as if it's moving
continuously
and so it is with with um
uh with things in these at the level of
atoms of space now can you be in a
situation
where sort of space has been so pulled
apart that it's really a big jump from
one place in space to another that may
happen
near rapidly rotating black holes and
maybe it happens in some other places as
well but yes in those kinds of places
the structure of space may have been so
pulled apart
that in a sense the distance between the
atoms of space is large and so you can
potentially see effects the most likely
effect there is that gravitational waves
that are produced by such a system uh
will have little gravitational waves
just like light waves
you know you can think of light as a
wave you can also think about as a
stream of photons so similarly you can
think about a gravitational wave
either as a wave or as a stream of
gravitons
and even things lower level than
gravitons that are essentially
distortions in the structure of space
gravitons are in a sense sort of a way
of describing distortions in the
structure of space that are quite big
gravitational waves and even bigger
tends to be an even bigger description
of things
um but there are much more microscopic
descriptions which happen down at the
level of atoms of space
just like when you say
the velocity of a fluid changes
you're saying the average velocity of
the fluid on a macroscopic scale changes
but down the level of individual
molecules all kinds of other changes
might be happening
so
uh let's see i was i was just describing
um
the uh yeah so there may be places where
sort of
space has been pulled apart enough
that when gravitational waves are
produced they will have little jitters
in them
that are a reflection
of the fact that the space that where
they are produced was not something that
was continuous it was something that had
been sort of pulled apart into discrete
items of space we don't know how big
that effect is whether it will be
measurable whether it be measurable
anytime soon we don't know that yet and
there's probably a certain degree of
cleverness in sort of finding ways to
amplify that effect
for example one project done at the
summer school looked at gravitational
lensing
so when
when light
a
lens made of glass for example works
from the fact that light rays that go
into the lens are bent because the speed
of light in the in the glass is maybe
one and a half times slower than the
speed of light and vacuum and so this
sort of front of light that goes in will
be bent and that's allows the lens to
like form an image you know do whatever
lenses do so you're looking through a
lens rather than looking directly at
light rays coming to you okay so gravity
bends light as well
and uh
and so when you have like a galaxy or
something or a black hole even
you can uh let's say a black hole
the the light
that goes that sort of comes around the
different sides of the black hole it's
bent and the light is tends to be
focused just like a lens
uh converging lens will focus parallel
rays of light we'll bring them to a
focus so if you take a magnifying glass
and you're looking at light from the sun
you can use that to make a bright spot
and you know burn a piece of paper or
something on a bright day because all
those rays of light that come to all
parts of the magnifying glass are all
being focused together to that one point
where you put much more energy so you
can burn the piece of paper so similarly
you can have instead of the magnifying
glass you have a black hole and light is
coming on the two sides of the black on
all the sides of the black hole and it
will be
it will be deflected by the gravity of
the black hole and so it will be made to
converge
and so what we actually see in their
lovely pictures of this is gravitational
lensing typically around galaxies um
where things from distant places will be
that that their light will be distorted
like this so it's conceivable somebody
worked out something at the summer
school about how gravitational lensing
works
in our models of
physics and space time and i think it's
conceivable that there might be some
kind of weird sort of scintillation
effect where you where you're seeing an
object that is behind gravitational
lensing that happens
because of the microscopic structure of
space that that might be an observable
effect and it might be that that with
long enough sort of baseline of how how
far you go from the gravitational
lensing event that you might be able to
see a measurable effect there you might
be able to essentially see a microscope
have a microscope that sees all the way
down to the level of atoms of space but
i don't know if that will work yet
um
okay
richard has commented i've listened to
live neurons and lab amplified to make
audible it's a strange experience yeah
i've listened to those two i mean
usually what happens is neurons are
quite quiescent maybe they're going but
every so often and then the neuron gets
excited and it has this
they can't do it you know much faster
that faster than that um where it's it's
suddenly woken up and it's like you know
uh sort of going crazy and and um uh
sending signals
normally to its other neurons or to the
electrode that you're using to measure
the neuron
and yeah i think the really weird thing
would be
if you had some kind of neural device
implement implanted in your brain and
you're like thinking about things and
suddenly some display comes up that says
you know that part of your brain just
started you know going crazy and like
you're thinking you have your big
macroscopic thoughts and yet something
is you know in your augmented reality
display or something something is
showing you by the way there's a thought
going on somewhere in your brain i don't
know what that would do for one i don't
know how that would feel
i mean the the closest analog of that is
neurofeedback where you're looking at
the eeg
which is kind of the large-scale
electrical effects on the brain and you
put a bunch of electrodes on your head
and um you can you know by the time the
electrical signals have gotten through
your skull and things like this they're
pretty they're pretty smooshed out
they're pretty smeared out but
nevertheless you can get some sense
of uh of the overall electrical activity
of your brain so for example if you fall
asleep the electrical the pattern of
electrical activity will change
completely what do you get you get
normally you have this thing called the
alpha rhythm which is kind of a about a
nine
about 10 cycles per second
of um
uh
your brain has kind of a large-scale uh
effect where it's sort of electrically
uh cycling about 10 times a second
that's absolutely pathetic compared to
your average computer which is cycling a
billion times a second or a few billion
times a second but but the actual speed
of neurons is is faster it's maybe 100
times faster than that sort of overall
collective uh alpha rhythm in the brain
when you go to sleep i think it's the
theta rhythm that starts up if i
remember correctly it's just a different
pattern of overall excitation in the
brain and so you can detect that
you can also detect some other things
that you can localize eg a bit and so
like there's a motor strip on the top of
one's head that is the thing that is the
sort of earliest
uh place where signals start developing
that will eventually control your
muscles and so on that will eventually
be sent down peripheral nerves to your
muscles and so on in your fingers or
whatever else
so then but um
uh
let's see and the the thing that you can
do in in kind of um you can try and
train yourself to know what it feels
like when
your brain is in a certain state
in a certain state as measured by your
eeg and i've i've tried this a few times
i haven't tried this in years my gosh
um
you know
tried this a few times where you're
where you're observing your your kind of
eeg your very aggregated brain state
and
then you're kind of trying to
learn what it feels like to just sort of
let your brain go blank or do whatever
else
um i
yes i remember doing this some gosh
nearly 20 years ago now
with a
person who was very big on biofeedback
and events with a bunch of biofeedback
technology for trying to you know let
one sort of learn to relax by by seeing
what this what
what it felt like to one when one made
one's brain
uh have certain eegs certain brain
activities i mean of course you know
it's kind of training one's brain
in the same kind of way that you might
train your brain
to write
you know handwritten letters or
something
by in that case the sort of a feedback
loop where you see where your fingers
move and your eyes sees where your
fingers move and that becomes the
feedback loop to your brain whereas eeg
is sort of in a sense a more direct
feedback loop of just seeing what your
intrinsic brain activity is i think it
would be much more bizarre if you had
single cell single neuron recording in
different parts to your brain and you're
like i'm just thinking about something
and suddenly as you think about that
thing bing this particular you know
neuron says i just woke up you know
you're thinking about um elephants oh
this neuron here woke up oh you're
thinking about rhinoceroses this neuron
here lit up very strange experience i
think that would be uh we're not quite
there yet but the closest analog of that
is is fmri
functional magnetic resonance imaging we
have to be in this big magnets and
things and you can measure uh the the um
uh the
basically the flow of power in your
brain the amount of
of oxygen that's being used the amounts
of glucose that's being consumed in your
brain and when when one part of your
brain is active the neurons are spiking
more they're generating more electrical
signals and as they generate more
electrical signals they need more uh
they need more fuel and their fuel this
glucose and their metabolism and so on
and so you can detect that effect with
with fmri but it's a pretty smeared out
thing it's not it's not like it's not
like individual neurons oh this
particular neuron lit up when you
thought about a rhinoceros or something
but it'll certainly be a strange thing
if you can have you know you're just
sitting here thinking and suddenly
there's a sort of uh feedback
of of of all these different neurons
that were involved
let's see
um
[Music]
richard comments will be the ultimate
biofeedback experience to visit
someone's own neural activation
spatially yeah to really really see in
real time
kind of different parts of your brain
lighting up and not i mean that would be
yeah it would be very interesting and
bizarre i mean as i'm you know yakking
at you right now there could be a little
icon of a little brain icon in the
corner and where it's like um uh you
know
like i know i have this figured out
and some piece of the frontal cortex
will light up or something or i'm not
sure what's what to you know what to say
next and some piece of some other lobe
of the brain would light up in one's
kind of telemetry display of what's
happening one's brain that'd be a very
weird experience and i think
it's some
you know it reminds me
of things where you're trying to measure
other kinds of aspects of of us like for
example i tried ages ago a thing which
measures
the um uh
kind of um
let's see the galvanic spits um
galvanic skin resistance galvanic
resistance i guess it's called so that's
your if you put electrodes across
across your skin
if if you sweat at all
then much more electricity is conducted
than if you don't sweat at all
and so you can kind of measure
uh you can measure
the extent to which you are micro
sweating so to speak by this change of a
galvanic skin
resistance response
galvanics
it's a resistance anyway it's a
resistance to electrical uh
to electricity
so
you know i remember i tried once one of
these little devices which measures that
and um i was at some event and i was uh
somebody was talking about something or
another there's some sort of semi-public
kind of thing and i was about to put my
hand up and ask some question
and i noticed that this galvanic skin
response thing uh started spiking and
it's like okay i'm you know it is of
higher stress to me to put my hand up
and ask a question than just to sit
there and do nothing and this was a sort
of precursor signal of that that you
could see in galvanic skin response
and i think that um you know there are
these rather rather hokey kind of
technological ideas of kind of lie
detectors and so on which um uh which is
supposed to say you know are you are you
feeling stressed when asked this
question that work by using similar
kinds of techniques but it's sort of
interesting to see that um
uh
that some things about your brain that
you're not necessarily conscious of um
are are measurable in that kind of way
even quite externally like in skin
response i i have to say that um i got
one of those devices and one of my kids
who's a pretty cool cucumber i would say
um is
uh was trying to see you know could he
could he you know detect things with
this galvanic skin response thing and he
tried all kinds of stuff and he couldn't
get it to move at all and you know he
tried watching you know a dramatic movie
he tried doing all kinds of things and
it was just
flatline
so um he's
perhaps cooler than i am i suppose
um
anyway
so i need to go in a few moments here
but maybe i can just um
uh
it's a question here from ll would there
be in theory a way to measure your
relative position in real space it's
sort of an interesting question i mean
the
you know my view of positions in rural
space is they're different
ways of describing the universe
and they are sort of the
where different minds are in different
places in rural space so for example you
know i'm where i am
somebody who thinks about things in a
similar way to me is kind of fairly
close
uh
you know
the um a random cat for example
is probably further away in rule space
there are certain kinds of things that i
can recognize in the cat that are you
know similar to me you know the cat wag
tail or purse or whatever else that's an
emotional response that i can sort of
recognize
as being aligned with an emotional
response that i might have
i can go further away than the cat but i
mean you know when i think about sort of
the nature of physics i have no idea
what the what the transport of that into
the cat brain is
when we go further away than that and we
start saying you know how does what is
the sort of rule space
associated with i don't know a colony of
bacteria
or you know the weather or something
like that
that translation that one has the sense
that that's much further away in rural
space that the translation from our mind
to the mind of the weather or to the
mind of our immune system or to the mind
of a bacterial colony one has the sense
that that's a much larger distance in
the wheel space
but
quantifying that is a super interesting
thing to do because we we can do it at a
much more theoretical level we can think
about we've got an idealized model of
computation like a turing machine here
we've got another idealized model of
computation maybe we've got the actual
cpu of our computer over here these are
again at different places in real space
but there we actually know the programs
that allow you to effectively be
transfer be transported from one to
another and so we can measure things
like the length of the program that's
necessary to translate from the direct
sort of inputs that will be used for the
turing machine to the inputs that will
be used for your cpu or vice versa
and somehow maybe the length of that
program gives on some sense of distance
in real space
but these are all things that that still
need to be really worked out
um
let's see
uh
well i think um yeah there are a lot of
interesting questions here
uh
well eggy is asking okay i'll maybe try
and take this one just for a second and
i should go it's asking how do new
concepts get created and integrated into
the mind of humanity what makes them
robust over a thousand years
yeah interesting question
um
their ideas
like the idea of having an abstract
description of the world
the idea of language
the idea of computation
these ideas once they are ingested into
human society become very robust
there are other ideas
like particular concepts in the
mathematics of the babylonians
the idea of loons
the idea of uh i don't know
uh
some the tetractus of pythagoras
there are other ideas that don't really
make it
and
it's sort of a little bit perhaps like
biological evolution
there are creatures that somehow are
going to make it and are going to get
big
get big in the sense that there are lots
of them and they and they've survived
for a long time there are other
creatures that get sort of stomped out
and what determines
uh you know so what gets big and what
doesn't
seems to be hard to tell
i think in the case of ideas
so an interesting question is
will there be more big ideas
or will the presence is the number of
big ideas that brains can deal with
somehow limited
and
as
a new idea comes along it has to be kind
of subsumed in other ideas
it's kind of like
you know you might say in modern times
there's just so much more to know than
there was in the middle ages let's say
that's why we need more years of
schooling
you could say that
you could say sort of as we've learned
more about science and
society and this and that and the other
there's just you know people should go
to school for many more years because
there's so much more to learn
but actually there's another effect
which is some things that people
learnt as
oh you learn
uh all the different kinds of um
oh i don't know
all the different uh forms of logical
argument
or something now we can subsume all of
that by just giving some principles of
logic that let you derive all of those
logical arguments it's not the best
example i could say you know might have
individually learnt
the um
all these different kinds of creatures
that hang out in a in your average uh i
don't know
average uh puddle or something like this
but
but in fact
through better understanding of biology
we know oh there are microorganisms
there are algae there are uh you know
there are insects there this that and
the other we've managed to bucket those
things together so we only have to learn
about insects sort of in aggregate once
rather than saying oh there's this kind
of that kind of that kind so as
knowledge progresses
there is both more that's known but
there's also a higher level of
abstraction about the knowledge that's
already there so it's possible to kind
of learn once learn one one principle
to cover a large number of what would
have been treated as individual facts so
it's not at all evident that just
because more has been discovered that
necessarily there's more to learn
because some of what could what's been
discovered is principles that aggregate
together many facts
so this question of what will be the
principles and how will the things that
we think about today sort of aggregate
together into principles it's actually
very beautiful in our model of physics
which has now spilled over into metal
mathematics and some other areas we
really see that effect because we see
these principles that seem to apply
across physics to meta mathematics and
probably many other areas and someday in
the future when people name something
more than just modern physics
there'll be modern modern
modern
modern
science or something
will be this aggregated thing where you
learn once the principles of
multi-computation and concepts like the
ruliad and things like this
and then you get to take that
abstraction and apply it in all these
different areas
rather than learning separately this is
how it works in physics that's how it
works in math this is how it works in
chemistry this is how it works in these
different places
so you know i i fully expect that that
will be a a robust concept though it may
take a while to sort of get to the point
where it is presented in a form that is
convenient for understanding see what
happens is an idea has to be presented
in a form that fits into
sort of human understanding as human
understanding exists today but once that
idea is fully planted it becomes the
basis for the understanding and it no
longer has to be seated so to speak
in
in sort of existing understanding it
just becomes an understanding in itself
just like when you first have the
concept of a chair for example you're
always having to explain what a chair is
but eventually the concept of a chair
becomes sort of a a separated thing that
you can then explain other things in
terms of you don't have to kind of go
back and explain what it's what it's
based on
all right i have to um
uh
disappear here to go and
do some things for my day job but um a
pleasure chatting with you guys and
thank you for asking some interesting
questions making some interesting
comments i had a chance to figure out
more about the woolly ad here
um
for
uh for those who are interested in these
things we have um uh our emerging
wolfram institute which is just getting
launched now
we'll have a whole uh area that's
studying the ruliad and studying sort of
the from the atoms of existence up
from there
and uh there are
lots of ways that are starting to be
there to get involved with that
um
the uh i will also say uh just a
reminder because i i said this at the
beginning i'm gonna say it again
you know i've been doing these q a's now
for a couple of years and we've
accumulated a pretty big library of
previous questions so um
um i encourage people to check those out
if you feel like it they've been turned
into podcasts and things like that
um of course uh some of the things that
i'll talk about are things that have
been around for decades and their
well-established knowledge related to
what i was just saying about the
evolution of knowledge but some of them
including things i talked about today
i um are very new some of the things
that i talked about today i figured out
in real time as i was talking to you
guys
um and uh uh you know that there and
some things are like weeks to months old
so if you look back at earlier things in
the um
in our kind of stack of um of uh
recordings of these um
uh of these live streams uh if you if
you look for things about the ruliad
well there won't be anything about the
ruliad two years ago because i hadn't
figured out the ruling ad two years ago
um but so things um this is this is a
place where you can actually see things
moving forward i might just say in
another little pitch
uh we do other live streams of kind of
working sessions where we're working on
both design of the company of the
wolfram language computational language
and also doing things about science
and uh if you want to know kind of what
the front lines of that look like
i encourage you to tune into those
things and uh
and check them out
all right uh well nice to chat with you
all
and see you another time
bye for now